Joe Biden at his own irredeemable
deplorable moment today we're going to
show you what he said Oh
Governor Cuomo for a full hour on my
radio show today he patched up some
differences more importantly how do we
open New York City how do we get Yankee
Stadium open how do we get you know the
Jets and Giants of the Meadowlands
playing I have my own thoughts I'll
share them with you but I got a
definitive answer from the governor also
on this question does this statement
hold for you if nominated I will not
accept if drafted I will not run if
elected I will not serve all right this
is what we call a tease the answer later
in the show but first let's get to the
major news from the president earlier
today he unveiled finally we can
hopefully move on it is a federal
government's three-phase plan to reopen
America again starting as early as May
first but actually earlier in some
places South Dakota never closed at all
even their restaurant stayed open take a
look
based on the latest data our team of
experts now agrees that we can begin the
next front in our war which we are
calling opening up America again and
that's what we're doing we're opening up
our country our national shutdown is not
a sustainable long term solution to
preserve the health of our citizens we
must also preserve the health and
functioning of our economy over the long
haul you can't do one without the other
my administration is issuing new federal
guidelines that will allow governor's to
take a phased and deliberate approach to
reopening their individual states now
you always have to remember I'm in New
York New York Long Island hardest hit in
the country thanks to farmers they
didn't shut down those that box up all
their items dairy everything in between
they didn't shut down truckers they got
honored rightly at the White House
earlier today we'll get more on that in
a second those medical supplies they
didn't shut down pharmaceuticals didn't
shut down those that build the math and
the gloves and the gowns and
the respirators and the ventilators they
all were working the whole country
didn't shut down now the details of this
plan include what will be a data-driven
multi-layered model which allows
governor's to react to their own State U
and their unique circumstances for
example as we talked a lot about densely
populated New York City will not be on
the same timeline as Montana or South
Dakota which never shut down anything
instead of a nationwide schedule well
the president's plan is broken into
three phases in order for a state to
begin the three-step process it has to
satisfy federal guidelines surrounding
hospital capacity ventilators available
personnel protective gear masks gloves
gowns etc this is now also in the hands
of governor's governor's wakeup a lot of
you some of you are asleep do your job
they are now asked for the ability to
make these decisions they got it you now
have the responsibility and if the
President and his task force see that
your messing up and hot spots are
emerging they will come down hard on you
phase one recommends continued
restrictions on non-essential travel it
discourages social gatherings of ten or
more people calls for Americans to
continue to work from home whenever
possible phase one also recommends large
venues like restaurants movie theaters
even gyms they can reopen but you got to
use very strict physical distancing
protocols and that would mean a lot of
Purell a lot of wipes
if the köppen 19 curve remains flat
states can then move to phase two that
phase schools can reopen non-essential
travel can continue bars can reopen with
limits on occupancy bars are going to be
tough ultimately the last step phase
three that would lift staffing
restrictions in the workplace it would
also lift distancing restrictions on
bars and restaurants that allows visits
to senior care facilities and hospitals
to begin again each phase of the plan to
get Americans back to work will take
extra precautions now especially in a
place like New York City now you got
this very small geographic area largest
concentration of people 11 million
people it's a it's a difficult task
Governor Cuomo of New York was on my
radio
Grahame for an hour today we talked at
length about all of this I shared my
views he shared his but it'll take a
little more work in a place like New
York City
take a listen there's gonna be a phasing
in and it is going to be different I
don't know different worse it might even
be different better but it's going to be
different look this is going to do what
9/11 did right if I ever told you before
9/11 you would have to take off your
shoes when you go to an airport and walk
through a metal detector on the line and
have them go through your bags people
who would say no how no way but 9/11
changed our orientation this is going to
change our orientation and people are
going to want to change it you know they
people want to be safe first of all some
of this is annoying as hell nobody wants
to wear gloves at a mask but for the
time being we're also doing it for the
people that are most vulnerable
underlying conditions compromised immune
systems now over the past several days
New York has seen thankfully finally
tremendous progress the flattening now
the decline the models are holding as we
hope they would Wednesday total
hospitalizations dropped by 600 that's
the largest decrease to date total
intubations dropped by 40 that also the
largest decrease and the death rate is
starting to decline that is the lagging
indicator as we talked a lot about for
this progress to continue in a place is
densely populated in New York City look
I know it sucks
I'll be honest residents there will need
to take important precautionary measures
now you want my plan we'll call it a
Hannity plan to reopen New York City
would be the it'd be the following mass
and gloves temporarily might be the new
normal in New York City even indoors not
essential workers well they're gonna
have to work for home at least 50% of
the workforce at every building in New
York 50% is the goal keep them working
at home that allows more social
distancing less concentration on the
streets and the buildings of New York
City digital temperature checks they
don't touch it and put it at your
forehead Bing Bing boom that has to
happen everybody entering any building
it should be mandatory again temporarily
into the if you want entrance into any
building in New York City I discussed
all this with the governor today I would
I want to see Yankee Stadium open
I want Citi Field where the Mets play
open I want MetLife Stadium in New
Jersey open for the Giants and Jets now
this is not my decision but now you have
to start with this one thing people most
at risk with underlying health issues or
compromised immune systems guys you
shouldn't go not this year you're gonna
have to take a year off every player
every trainer every coach have retic a
taker every food and beverage worker
anybody working in these stadiums will
have to have that Abbott five-minute
Test have to anyone that wants to attend
the game now if I have the choice
attending the game and not attending the
game I'm just speaking for myself
consult your doctor I'm not a doctor but
you must get the temperature test to get
into any the Yankee Stadium you get the
temperature test you have a temperature
they give you information you go to your
doctor be safe at home how to do contact
tracing no can't have a database god I
respect medical privacy but you can't be
if you have a temperature going into any
even outdoor stadium now temporarily
again not the best conditions but if
it's my choice and I have to wear gloves
a mask okay I'll wear it I'd rather go
and wear it if everyone else is wearing
it we can suck it up for a couple of
months until things have passed probably
can't eat popcorn because you have to
keep your mask off the whole time but
you probably could eat a hotdog you take
a it open up your respirator take a bite
and you chew it under your mask I have
to drink my beer if I'm at a game so if
I have to use a straw and slip it in
I'll do that whatever it takes to get my
beer I want to have a beer everyone's
got to make their own decision what is
your appetite for any risk there are you
getting a car it's risk you that I have
to decide consult with your own doctor I
would rather have my temperature taken
drink beer from a straw eat a hot dog by
going like this and chewing it at a mass
that not go at all that's my decision
you make yours now I'm pro-choice
I know this is not ideal but if it's
about saving the lives especially if
other people more vulnerable and getting
our economy back up and running full
speed as quickly as possible I'll suck
it up and I think a lot of New Yorkers
would suck it up and want to go to the
game where the masks and gloves and
maybe the Yankees and the Giants and
Jets and Mets can make their own masks
and hand them out as you go in with
their emblems on it I don't know just an
idea medical privacy a must we can't be
compromised no government databases
sorry we have a constitution we have
civil liberties people can decide to go
or not go based on these temporary rules
I choose to go say what football say
what outdoor concerts indoor events yeah
I think well you could move the New York
Rangers to and the island is to Yankee
Stadium and Citi Field they do that at
least once a year anyway recent poll by
the way shows that some Democrats a
majority of them would likely support
mandatory nationwide blood testing and
electronic ankle bracelet for those who
are sick no I'm not taking that all
right